Earlier this year, the bracket system was rolled
out in the commander format, providing guidelines
for separating decks into different rough
groupings to be played together. Soon after,
though, I noticed a problem. I noticed a problem—I
didn’t have any bracket two decks. I had a lovely
variety of different bracket 3 decks from
battlecruiser to aggro to control to low-slung
staxy midrange, but nothing I’d feel comfortable
consistently pulling out in games against three
precons or equivalent decks, at least not without
the expectation of playing a 1v3 archenemy sort
of role. So, that seemed like a problem worth
remedying. Now, I had built a low-power deck
in the past—a couple years previously I’d built a
Skeleton Ship proliferate deck, and that was kind
of funny, but it was lower power purely because
it ran a hot garbage commander and a number of
hot garbage cards in the 99 such as Shrine of
Piercing Vision, Mindless Automaton, Time Bomb,
and a whole four of the 90s storage lands that
couldn’t tap for non-stored mana. It was funny,
but the play pattern was jarring, with the deck
being glacially slow to get going but potentially
quite oppressive in the late game if it was
left alone to fully build up an engine. You can
probably imagine why I mostly stopped playing this
deck. One alternative option for having a bracket
2 deck would be just buying a precon, and maybe
doing a slight round of upgrades or sidegrades,
but I wanted something that felt more my own
than that. There’s also another problem with both
precons and the Skeleton Ship deck—they feel kinda
suboptimal. This probably sounds like a very silly
criticism of a deck intended to play in relatively
low-power games, but I really like the process
of tightening up a deck’s cohesion, of finding
the perfect cards for its mechanical needs, the
process of turning the deck into a machine that
does something. I like that process and I like to
play decks that feel like they’re performing the
role I want them to perform as well as they can.
Immediately this is a bit of a conflict—this
preference for optimization works fine for
bracket 3, because there are a whole lot of
somewhat funky ideas whose optimized version
ends up in that sort of nice mid-power zone.
But bracket 2 is harder—what sort of idea is
so inherently mediocre that optimizing it ends up
at the power level of a precon? In this case, I
actually took inspiration from precons themselves.
See, preconstructed commander decks are typically
unfocused by design—they feature slightly too
many themes and elements because they’re trying to
give players a taste of different playstyles, and
also give some easy paths to upgrade a given deck
such as cutting a singular subtheme for some more
relevant stuff. So, what if I did the same thing,
but on overdrive: what if I built a deck
with way too many subthemes, like a truly
irresponsible number of subthemes, and then
tried my hardest to optimize it into a workable
decklist? Thus began the process of building
Phyrexian-flavored Subtheme Soup. Longtime
Snail heads out there might remember that I had a
Glissa Sunslayer battlecruiser deck a while back,
and while I love Glissa as a character, both
that deck and that Glissa ran a bit generic for
my tastes. Glissa the Traitor could be fun
as an old-school sort of commander choice,
but that one is actually a bit too specific for
my purposes her, with a setup and payoff that
don’t offer a super wide variety of options.
However, there’s another green black option,
and that one actually lands right in the sweet
spot for me—Glissa, Herald of Predation. This is
a 5 mana 3/5 that offers a choice at the beginning
of combat on your turn—Incubate 2 twice, flip all
your incubator tokens, or give your Phyrexians
first strike and deathtouch. Incubate as a
mechanic is pretty unique—it creates a noncreature
artifact token with +1/+1 counters on it that
can later be flipped into a Phyrexian artifact
creature by paying two mana. Obviously this lends
itself to a deck that cares about counters,
so we’ll call that subtheme #1, but honestly
the first thing I noticed about Glissa is “wow
this card generates a lot of artifact tokens”.
There’s a number of fairly straightforward ways
to take advantage of having artifact tokens. Cards
like Tarrian’s Journal and Eviscerator’s Insight
sacrifice artifacts to draw, Monumental Corruption
can either be a big draw spell or a player-killing
spell depending on the artifact count, and Throne
of Geth is a potent one-card engine with the
commander, also boosting the counters theme. So
for our purposes here, having a lot of artifacts
is subtheme #2, and it’s one of the more central
themes here. It also contains arguably the deck’s
most powerful card, and one that inspired much
of the rest of the list—Clock of Omens. This is a
four mana artifact that allows a player to tap two
artifacts to untap a different artifact, and while
it’s not quite a combo piece here—I think—it still
has the potential for some big turns. The most
basic version of that is with some of my bigger,
counter-based mana rocks—repeatedly tapping and
untapping Everflowing Chalice, Astral Cornucopia,
or Empowered Autogenerator can really push the
deck’s mana into new territory and let it do
some big plays. There are a lot of other options
as well, though—Idol of Oblivion for card draw,
Staff of Compleation for proliferates and
more, and both Twitching Doll and Lux Cannon
as cool cards that also use counters. The deck
contains a couple other options for untapping,
but it does sometimes run into a problem—not
all of the cool tap abilities I want to run
are on artifacts. I have cards like Plaguemaw
Beast and Wight of the Reliquary that take
advantage of my tokens, and I’d quite like
to activate them repeatedly after flipping
a bunch of incubators with Glissa, so…
what if I just turned them into artifacts?
Enter the liquimetal package. This features
Liquimetal Torque and Phyrexian Scriptures,
both cards that can turn a creature into an
artifact creature, as well as being a mana
rock and a board wipe, respectively. This
package also contains two other cards, and
these are actually my two favorite cards in the
deck—Dollhouse of Horrors and Nexus of Becoming.
Both of these create token copies of cards
that are also artifact creature constructs,
with Dollhouse doing this by exiling creatures
from the graveyard and Nexus doing this by exiling
artifacts or creatures from a player’s hand. The
downside of exiling the copied card is certainly
real, but the potential volume of liquimetal-ed
creature creation is really potent here. And,
due to a particular quirk of these cards, they’re
able to form the bedrock for yet another one of
the deck’s subthemes—token copy populate. Since
the artifact creature copies created by Nexus
and Dollhouse are tokens, they can be further
copied by cards like Selesnya Eulogist and Esika’s
Chariot, cards that copy tokens. This can allow
for some nutty levels of advantage building, and
to improve the odds for things to come together
I threw in a few extra token copy generators as
well. This still isn’t a huge package—just five
setup and four payoff—but most of these cards
are fine enough on their own, and the payoff
for putting them together can be pretty huge.
A late edition to this deck was a graveyard
subtheme. I adore Dollhouse of Horrors and on
paper it’s perfect for this deck, but too often
in my early games I was finding myself without
much to do with it, making copies of maybe one or
two creatures but not feeling like I was getting
the full potential out of the card. This was
also my experience with another card I like,
Vat of Rebirth, so I decided to help these cards
out with the addition of some other graveyard
payoffs and especially some more graveyard
enablers. I went with mostly pretty flexible
options here—Millikin as a card that’s also
a mana dork, Sarinth Steelseeker as a sort
of value engine that works well with my artifact
tokens, Old Rutstein as a card that also itself
pushes my tokens plan, and Tyvar as a planeswalker
that also ties into activated abilities. With the
graveyard package covered we’ve capped off the
list of all the major subthemes, but there are
a few more minor packages as well. The deck runs
a constructs package with Scrapyard Recombiner,
which gives it access to a removal spell and a
few synergy options of different calibers. There’s
also five cards that create powerstones, which
can pay for one of the deck’s 31 artifacts, one of
the deck’s 23 cards with a colorless-mana-payable
activated ability, or any of the incubator tokens
Glissa makes. For the weirdest little tidbit here,
the deck can actually populate incubator tokens.
This might seem bad since the copy won’t enter
with counters and will instantly die when flipped,
or instantly instantly if it’s already on the
creature side, but this actually allows for
on-demand usage of on-death trigger cards
like Dross Scorpion and Morbid Opportunist
without needing a sac outlet. Sort of like
aristocrats without the aristocrats, I guess.
So this deck kind of does a little bit of
everything, and all of that everything is anchored
by Glissa. The artifact tokens she provides are
certainly a big help for sacrificing and whatnot,
but the biggest thing Glissa does is provide the
deck with a reliable wincon. Typically I’ll try
to ramp out Glissa on turn 4 and start gradually
accumulating incubators, maybe sacrifice one here
or there. Once that’s up and chugging, I can just
focus on cobbling together whatever stupid little
engine I have the tools to create, whether that be
a value engine, a ramp engine, a removal engine,
or some combination of these things. What’s
important is that I eventually find my way
to some proliferate, at which point I can use my
resource advantage to amplify the counters on my
accumulated tokens before having Glissa flip them,
allowing me to swing big at an opponent. The fact
that such an absurdly complex and multifaceted
deck typically wins by swinging in with a bunch
of vanilla 6/6s is a pretty juicy morsel of irony,
and it really lets the deck feel truly belonging
in bracket 2. And actually, this feature about
the deck is part of what helps it stay comfortably
bracket 2. In theory this deck has some gross
plays—first of all, there’s an infinite mana combo
that involves popping out Empowered Autogenerator
as a creature with Nexus of Becoming before
repeatedly untapping it with Voltaic Construct
the following turn. It’s a rather strange one
and requires a nontrivial amount of setup, but
it is still a three card combo. In addition,
the deck features pretty powerful cards
like Clock of Omens, Kudoltha Forgemaster,
and Staff of Compleation, and these can help the
deck assemble some pretty disgusting engines.
Despite this, I have not once had a win with
this deck that didn’t heavily involve Glissa,
and that puts a natural cap on things. As
long as she’s out, I get two incubators
per turn every turn, but that’s all I get. I can
make them bigger—in some cases a lot bigger if
I had a proliferate engine really pop off—but
I’m still going to be winning the game with a
fairly ordinary and extremely predictable
number of most-likely-vanilla creatures.
So that’s the deck, and I do find it
quite fun, but I worry that the process
of describing it might be making it seem a bit
more functional than it actually is. A deck that
tries to cram in as many subthemes as possible
is naturally going to struggle with dead cards,
when the cards intended to work with those
cards decide not to show up. The only deck
I have that comes even close to this one
in terms of complexity is my Sharuum deck,
but there’s a pretty clear difference between
these two—that deck is a toolbox deck that runs
11 conditional tutors to help it piece together
engines, whereas this deck has two tutors. I
don’t know if there’s been an exact tutor limit
given for bracket 2, but I’ve heard the number
3 floated around and that felt like a nice
number to shoot for here that would force some
creative workarounds without being an outright
barrier against tutoring. All this to say,
with the daring vision and self-imposed
restrictions I had going into this deck,
dead cards were inevitably going to be a
challenge. So, how does this deck mitigate that?
A big one is that I try pretty hard not to let
a card perform only one task for the deck. There
is no generic removal here—when I highlight the
cards in my interaction suite that proliferate,
use counters, or are lands in Archidekt, that
excludes only five cards, and all of those either
fit into another subtheme or have some sort of
useful synergy in a removal engine. The same goes
for the ramp—of the deck’s 19 cards that perform
some sort of ramp function, the two most generic
are Golgari Signet and Talisman of Resilience,
with every single other one involving counters,
producing powerstones, or otherwise slotting
into one of the deck’s themes. Likewise for draw,
with Morbid Opportunist being by far the most
generic of the deck’s 17 sources of value,
and that’s even considering the weird populate
trick I mentioned earlier. Something else you
might notice here is that the number of
ramp and draw spells are fairly high,
and this is another pretty essential feature
for letting the deck run smoothly. Since there
are single digit counts of setup and payoff for a
number of different subthemes throughout the deck,
it becomes very important to see more of the
deck in order to piece together engines. I
actually bought a couple of draw engines on the
convention floor at MagicCon Vegas because I was
noticing some light stallouts in the games
I was playing, and sure enough that helped
the deck out quite a bit. This also applies
to ramp—since there’s no guarantee that the
low-cost cards I have available will be what I’m
looking for in a given moment, having some extra
ramp to let me use activated abilities and more
expensive cards instead also contributes a bit of
flexibility. Having a high count of ramp is also
quite helpful since the deck has a relatively high
mana commander that’s relatively central to its
gameplan, and always having the mana to replay
her kinda lets me avoid needing to think too hard
about how consistent my alternate wincons are.
Despite this effort, there are still ongoing
challenges here. Some subthemes just don’t
really have cards that are good on their
own, or which tie into other themes.
Selesnya Eulogist and Rootcast Apprenticeship are
somewhat subpar interaction if I don’t have token
copies, the two non-clock untapping effects
are both fairly restrictive in their effect
even if their ceiling is high. And, that’s to
say nothing of the graveyard package. I might
have made it sound like I had the problem of
not enough cards for Dollhouse to reanimate
and I solved it by adding 4 or 5 graveyard
enablers, but honestly it still feels like
barely enough—the card still runs out of useful
stuff to copy pretty regularly. In addition,
there’s another similar card I want to add to this
deck—God-Pharaoh’s Gift has a higher upfront cost
but is otherwise pretty similar to Dollhouse
of Horrors, making token copies of creatures
in graveyard by exiling them. This is another one
of my favorite cards, but it currently makes no
sense at all here—it’d have the same problems as
Dollhouse in not having enough targets to copy,
and it doesn’t even tie into the tap/untap,
liquimetal, or construct subthemes like Dollhouse
does. There are two problems with the graveyard
package currently—only 6 cards that put cards
into the yard at the moment, and only 23 total
creatures in the deck. It’s kinda discouraging
to do the math on this—if I’ve gone through 20
cards of my deck, I’ve only seen 4 or 5 creatures,
and the number of those that have made their way
to the graveyard is almost certainly less than
that. Current goals for the deck are increasing
the creature count, finding a third tutor for the
deck that helps alleviate current challenges, and
possibly fleshing out other packages as well. My
maybeboard on archidekt goes kinda crazy—I
have four different categories of possible
additions within the maybeboard, in addition to
a more generic category. If you have ideas for
how to cram more deck into this deck, please
let me know. I’d genuinely love to hear them.
It’s funny when I think about what advice I’d
give if somebody else presented this deck to me
saying they wanted to make it better. Because, the
answer is obviously “please cut some subthemes,
you have way too many of them.” Why am I spending
deck space on tap/untap cards other than Clock
of Omens? Why am I going to the effort of a
copy populate package? Why am I bothering to
integrate graveyard synergies into this? Why am
I even thinking about aristocratless aristocrats?
A sensible player trying to improve this would
cut most of the graveyard support, at least two
of the populate cards, and all of the token copy
cards aside from Nexus of Becoming. But that’s the
joy of this deck to me—I shouldn’t be doing what
I’m doing if I wanted a deck that plays smoothly,
and the fact that I’m doing it anyway is what
makes this a bracket 2 deck. It’s the same
reason this deck includes some kinda-not-great
proliferate cards. Would a sensible player trying
to upgrade this deck include Plaguemaw Beast,
Carnivorous Canopy, and Spread the Sickness?
Probably not! But it’s not like I’m going to
be playing these flavorful cards anywhere else,
and here they’re… fine. They feel acceptable.
And that’s pretty cool if you ask me.
Thanks for watching! I talked a bit about
my Skeleton Ship deck in this video,
and if you want to know more about that I posted
a short video for supporters discussing that deck,
its play patterns, its pitfalls, and
some of the dumbest games I had with it.
If you want the full version, you can join my
Patreon or become a YouTube member, but there will
be a sneak preview for it in about 10 seconds.
I also released an older patron video about my
original Glissa deck over on my 2nd channel,
with some included commentary of why I swapped
it out for a new deck, so you can also check that
out. With that, it’s time to enter the bone zone.